-Guys, it's Tuesday. It's time
for "We-Tweet." Here we go.
-♪ We-Tweet ♪
♪ We-Tweet ♪
-Welcome to "We-Tweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets
and we're all going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Now, you can -- Yeah.
Just grab the one --
Was it to your left?
I think it's on the left.
-Yeah.
-Some people it's on the right.
Very confusing.
That's half the fun of the game.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you can all -- you can vote
for all of them,
or you can vote for
none of them.
Whatever you want.
I just want you to have fun
and enjoy yourself.
But we're going to see
the results live.
So, you might as well --
-You might as well vote.
-You might as well vote,
just to see where this ends up.
Higgins, you have your clicker.
-Got my clicker.
-Whatever tweet gets
the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show
so you can all like it
and "we-tweet" it.
-Nice.
-Thank you.
It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, here we go.
The first tweet is --
I like this one, I think.
Alright, ready?
Seesaws are basically
friend scales.
[ Light laughter ]
Like friend scale. Yeah.
Goes up, goes down.
Well, I can already tell by the
silence, the stunning silence
from the audience that I don't
feel like this is going to be --
-No, I don't think it's going to
be a big hit.
-No. I liked it.
I think it's funny.
-It's clever, sure.
-Yeah.
I don't think people enjoyed it.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Yeah. That's a no. That's a no.
[ Laughter ]
That'll be a no, Bob.
-That's what we call
a resounding no.
-Yeah, that'll be
Alright, let's try
this next one. Alright?
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Might be a comparison --
I think this one is going to get
more than 77.
-Wait, what's that now?
You think it's going to get
more than 77?
-Yeah, 'cause in comparison to
the last one, this one's better.
-Oh, I see what you're saying.
So, compared to the last one,
this one's better.
So you think this will get
more than 77%.
-90.
-You're going to say 90?
I think it's going to do
pretty well.
I'm gonna say it's over a hundy
on this one.
-You sure?
-Yeah, let's take a look.
Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
-Bang!
141.
-Nice.
-There we are, that's number two
right there.
How about this one, here?
Oh, alright. This one's good.
This one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. That's nice. It's fun.
-Pretty good.
-And the answer is
a math conundrum.
-Yeah.
You know, it was a slow roll.
-Some people were like
"Absolutely not."
And then they go,
"Eh, you know what? Not bad."
-"Three, there's three.
You said two."
-And this is just a tweet.
So, I mean -- Like, yeah.
-It's just fun.
-Yeah. It's just fun.
-It's supposed to tickle
your insides.
-Tariq, what do you think of
this one?
-It's a no for me, dawg.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard that somewhere.
-Randy Jackson?
-Let's see the results.
Wow!
-Yeah! Yeah!
-See, it made people feel good.
It made people feel good,
I love that.
-Yeah.
-Good, I'm glad.
So, Lake Superior's out.
That one's in.
Alright, here we go.
[ Laughs ]
This -- Well, who knows?
I don't want to sell them.
-You don't want to sell them.
-They're all great.
Alright. This one says...
[ Laughter ]
That's when your real self
comes out.
Yeah, you're just like --
alright, you're like...
That's your real self.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, 159.
-Wow.
-Close.
-Almost but no cigar.
-Alright,
here's the last one right here.
You ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-It says...
There you have it.
Cast your votes right there.
I think I know what the winner's
going to be.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, I think the votes
have been cast.
Let's see the results.
Yes. Alright.
So number three is the winner.
We have, "There are two kinds of
people in this world.
People great at math,
people who are okay at math,
and people who are bad at math."
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a we-tweet and enjoy.